thank you that's that's our motto by the
way if you don't know that's what we
chose
of all the mottos in the world god save
the queen
i like yours more you guys went big you
guys went with god bless america
that's pretty optimistic that's a whole
country we
we were very modest we're just like
please keep a little old lady alive
just a couple more years we don't want
her son
if i'm honest he looks weird
and and god save has always felt weird
to me as a british person who's very
polite
save is so demanding we're not used to
that word and you guys
you guys went polite you guys said bless
god bless we should swap right you can
have god save america
seems fitting for the state that we are
in oh wow
things are happening what a what a time
to be here
but i'll be okay though cause i have
this voice
and guys they don't tell you this if you
have a british
accent it solves all your problems i
don't even need to be funny i just need
to talk
that wasn't even a joke that was just
inflection
and you believe anything i say as well
this is like
if wikipedia had an accent it's this one
i convinced a man in san diego that
maple syrup is just honey
that's made by canadian bees
funny thing is you don't even realize
how racist america is until after you
leave
you know like i did a show not too long
ago in edmonton canada
there was no racist vibe in edmonton
well first of all ain't no [ __ ] out
there so anybody be mad at
but i must have walked around that
[ __ ] for four days looking for a
black person
finally i saw one i ain't even know the
[ __ ] i just ran up to him and
hugged him like [ __ ] where you been
we need to stick together he was
offended he was like dude get your hands
off of me bro
that's like totally absurd i was like
[ __ ] they got him
it was too late i couldn't save them
i had white kids looking at me like i
was an exotic animal
it was like mom look at him he's so
chocolatey
i want one he kept trying to pour milk
on me i was like ain't gonna change
colors
[ __ ] off me
and i see some of the white of y'all
getting uncomfortable don't get
uncomfortable
i love white people man y'all my people
too it's just certain [ __ ] i can't do
with you
like go drinking every time i do a show
in front of white people after the show
you always want to hang out and buy me a
drink i can't drink with y'all
it's not that i don't want to it's just
i can't hang you [ __ ] are the
undisputed champs a drink
y'all drink to your fault the [ __ ] out
and i know when y'all get good and drunk
because that's that noise you'll make
don't do that that's scare black folk
there's a lot of bad history behind that
noise
black people we hit whoa we started
looking out for pickup trucks where the
[ __ ] they at
see this one like [ __ ] with earl he
played too much
i'm serious a party ain't a party to
y'all to the [ __ ] cops show up
and black people y'all know we see the
police party over
white people y'all have a freedom we
just don't have y'all see the police
y'all get braver
dude what's your [ __ ] badge number in
your name no don't [ __ ] touch me what
if i [ __ ] touch you
no you shut the [ __ ] up and move along
ares why are you crying relax
do you know who my dad is i'll sue i
swear to god get the [ __ ] on
black people we'd be in the back doing
sign language
and then you know there's where else
there's
this is the new world you know and the
other part of the new world is is
america
people think that's got a lot of promise
still
even though we're all a bit funny about
americans now a bit i think the reason
that
happened all that bad feeling about
america
is apart from everything that they've
done
it's because american stupid people
sound stupider than every other
kind of stupid person some people are
just
fake but you put up with them but
americans are annoying when they
think because they say well you know i
was if there's talking about one of
those terrible incidents that happened
every
other day in america to say well you
know i was there and the guy came in
and he had like a gun you know and he
was like
shooting and everybody else was totally
dead and you just
it sounds a little divorced from reality
somehow
so i think that's why there's this ill
feeling about the place sometimes
because of everything the administration
has done you know it's like the really
bad flatmate of the world oh sorry did i
break all your [ __ ] i didn't know it was
yours
yeah i'll replace it sometime um
with my stuff and because it's the only
remaining empire
of course you had an empire once britain
had a great empire and
impressively commandeered and
sequestered from the rest of the world
great style you just marched in and said
you you and you
[ __ ] off we're having tiffin
and everybody's already hot right
everybody off now that's fine and
it took centuries for people to go hang
on a minute
we live here the american style is
totally different
far more insidious this empire is
running a totally different basis what
america does is it has a nosey in some
place some war-torn [ __ ] up place
and that looks for oil or chocolate or
whatever it wants
all the indigenous people obviously get
pissed off and they begin to meet
they begin to foment they ring each
other up and say you
have a what let's meet and ferment at
six o'clock in the local
bombed out cafe they gather around and
they say
why don't we go i'm good doing a pan
global accent okay
it saves time because america gets
around a lot of places why don't we
and this represents poverty
hey listen hi
[Applause]
listen what are we gonna do about the
[ __ ] imperialistic yankee big dog huh
they come in here they [ __ ] they look
around they take our stuff what we're
gonna i'm talking to you put down the
beans listen
al pacino from china via brooklyn but
the um
and then what america does all these
people are talking
and very very gradually builds a
starbucks around
them and then they all become addicted
to latte and
they lose the will to rebel
[Applause]
and then they turn into americans
after a couple of weeks the kind of
people who come up to me and say hi
i i'm irish my grandmother was an old
flaherty did you know her
i always say yes yes i do
but then again everybody did
now that's a particular kind of american
obviously the kind of americans you see
in europe who often for some reason
seem to be very generously proportioned
and
you see them in museums blocking up the
exhibits going what is this can we eat
it where are we can we pee
and yet when you go to america you see
that it's a
very very uh because it's so competitive
and everything people are
ultra fashionable and very thin really i
think the americans you see in europe
are all the ones who stay in their
apartments get food piped in and then
they're just shipped out
to europe and but the ones over there
you see these amazing
looking people they don't look real at
all these incredibly exiguous women you
know those people who look like they
can't support the weight of their own
teeth and their head
stalking in and out of fashionable
restaurants i don't know what they do in
there maybe they just rub
pesto on their legs or something and
they know they look like they weigh as
much as a photograph of themselves and
and
very fashion conscious but people have
this idea that it's that it's still the
the promised land you know somewhere
like california which
everything is fruitful and and abundant
but
arnold schwarzenegger is
is the governor of california
there's a perfectly ordinary english
sentence
how did that happen do you know how that
happened
because i'll tell you you know how he
got into that position
he got there by lifting things
now you and me we avoid lifting things
it's unpleasant especially heavy things
even a five-year-old child knows this
they go huh
no [ __ ] it no i'm gonna put lego up my
arse i'm not doing that no
he took a different approach he lifted
the heavy and you know you lift
something when you have to
piano falls on granny you lift the piano
because granny has mixed feelings about
the whole situation
sunday lunch continues
he didn't do any of that he went right
over to the heavy thing
and lifted it i put it back down and
didn't move it anywhere
and then he lifted it again hundreds of
times
and said to the people who had stopped
to observe this aberrant behavior
look how good i am at lifting the heavy
thing
in my underpants now that
sounds a little dim
but it was they who said you're the man
you're the one we want to deal with
immigration and water rates and taxes
and all that kind of [ __ ]
no wait
[Applause]
what we need to know is how bad was his
predecessor at that job you know
this must have been somebody who came to
work covered in children's blood every
morning
those guys always get on on the
cross-country [ __ ] flights
so anyways there was this adorable uh
woman next to me
and uh she was from australia had the
little [ __ ] uh
accent and all that type of [ __ ]
so whatever long story short we're
taking off from jfk and one of the
runways is shut down
so it's taken for [ __ ] ever right a
couple people on the plane are in
wheelchairs so that takes more time you
know your proverbial fat [ __ ] you know
the whole deal
so uh we take off like an hour and a
half late either just the whole [ __ ]
that time we land we land there's no
gate and then we got to sit there and
wait to get towed in the whole thing's
taking forever and she just does this
[ __ ] where she just goes
she says she goes is everything in
america slow
you know so i let it slide
and then the plane lands and we're all
trying to see who won the celtics of the
lakers because we all missed the [ __ ]
game thank god espn showed the replay i
cut the second half
and it goes around the plane like
wildfire fire you know the celtics want
celtics one
and this girl in my moro was joking
about how much people give this [ __ ] and
then this girl makes comics something
you know americans [ __ ] blah blah
blah
and it's just like you know what i let
it slide with the first [ __ ] one but
it's just really you know
like they always talk about the ignorant
american what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
comes here from another country
and shits on the country to somebody
who's from this country
when i was over in england i didn't walk
around saying to english people how
[ __ ] awful their torsos were i didn't
do that
they said i enjoyed england i'm like
it's [ __ ] great i can't believe i'm
over here
royal albert hall it's beautiful i can't
wait to come over here again
phenomenal [ __ ] city i didn't say
your food sucks
you guys all have will ferrell mushy
torsos
i didn't say any of that [ __ ] i didn't
talk about your teeth being [ __ ] up
i didn't talk about the weird inbred
look because you've all been [ __ ]
each other
and the same goddamn strip of land for
[ __ ] thousands of years i didn't do
that [ __ ] i was on my best behavior and
here i am sitting next to this [ __ ]
clam
is everything in america slow as opposed
to what
that beacon of speed that [ __ ]
australia is
[ __ ] people you know i went to
australia i was there for like three
days
i had a good time down there but you
know i could have picked that place
apart
all the unemployed people just sitting
in bars drinking
[ __ ] it you know same [ __ ] [ __ ]
same goddamn just
[ __ ] that's all it is everybody taking
pot shots in america now
that's what it is because we've been on
top and we've been exploiting their
labor
and i guess maybe that's maybe we
deserve a little bit of that [ __ ] but
you know what take look in the [ __ ]
mirror
australia or a woman from australia
the [ __ ] i went there i was just like
wow like i was going into the future
can i have a ham and then the [ __ ]
sandwiches write my hand before i even
finish it
i didn't find them to be overly fast
over there either
you wait you [ __ ] wait you think it's
not coming your way
our corporations are just ahead of the
curve
of where where your corporations are our
corporations have basically exploited
every last legal way that they can make
more [ __ ] money over here so now
they're just stealing
they're just stealing and they're
cutting [ __ ]
staff members i actually had to wait
like a half hour 40 minutes to get my
bag last night
i think it was that sunday thing once
again it's sunday
it's sunday so we just have like a
skeleton crew
i don't know all i'm saying you know
it's just bugging me it's like do you
think i know that
that [ __ ] isn't a little [ __ ] up over
here do i need you to come over here
i would never be in australia and go
like yeah australians
to another [ __ ] australian you know
that's the type of [ __ ] i just felt like
[ __ ] stuffing her
in a goddamn boogie board bag boogie
board bag why did i pick that because i
saw that documentary of that stupid [ __ ]
from australia
who's put 200 pounds of [ __ ] weed
into her boogie board bag
right alliteration for you and then goes
to like bali
you know if you even have cold
medication they hang you by your balls
in the public square
and she gets life imprisonment well
that's what you get you dumb
[ __ ] that's what you get
that's one of my theater [ __ ] australia
that's how it works you see that's how
it works right there
there's a lot of people in australia
right now maybe listen to this [ __ ]
going you know i would never say that
i would never do that if i went yeah
well one of you did
so there you go do you think germany
likes to be judged by hitler alone
they don't i bet there's a lot of
sweethearts over in germany
look at all those [ __ ] fat jolly
people during oktoberfest
running around dressed like they're in
hansel and gretel you know
[ __ ] on each other or whatever weird
fetishes they're into over there